mm girl - very posh welcome to Marvis
it's so much fun
hope you enjoyed the episode we take
roleplay very seriously in this one
mistake error error so oh why you hit me
behind you behind you Michele it's Paula
it's Paula be cool be cool wait wait I
know it's a parlor when they see at the
parlor or there can be multiple people
not just one Oh it'd be cool we've
always wanted to be good friends with EJ
Canada Canada Stanley thanks Kenneth
clucking how's that alright tell me
everything about your experience okay I
need to go to the showers like thanks go
to the showers together why don't we
shall do it what was that they help of
surprise I don't worry I was just good
with my own shadow
it's called filling seananners trust you
can do thing okay each other
Kenneth may have a lot of blood on his
outfit but can I do a scavenger than a
Lia because he just said Kenneth I have
very beautiful feet
I trust Canada got em all night slacker
now say yes of an issue oh you're a bit
of a pickle just want to play video are
you guys gonna very much like the shower
with you don't worry about seconds okay
alien Peter Saunders here just good old
cowboy
I'm here to exterminate any any alien
activity sure we should hook up man
it's like in the movies and then we'll
probably get murdered together but we'll
love each other for at least only about
30 seconds Tammy's are you Oh God oh
sorry chambers I just had my procedure I
like to poke people make sure they're
not alien you know that cool were you I
should have asked for I know my Tammy -
Tammy Tammy you see this Bobby how I
stay in a procedure said god damn it
damn it damn it I was hoping I could
hook up with that I guess hello my name
is ender ender ender I know it's the
first time we meet each other just
educate you sure we're all good okay
we're simply what they can kill the
aliens how about I poke you or you poke
me once sure okay no no no no no that
was more than one okay you saw that hi
hi witness witnesses oh gosh you're ugly
what spoken were poking each other oh
that was a gentle poke it's a party
press hope you enjoy this episode if you
did go ahead and leave a like it helps
me out a lot and subscribe to become a
birthday
I'll see you silly already and I spot